it's only concerned with following every
rule and the patrol guide meet more
robot captain engage there's not what
you think
hey new captain alert you must be the
new CEO I am detective Jake Peralta
great to meet you no don't let me
interrupt you we're describing what kind
of person I'm gonna be I'd like you to
finish it's not necessary or I could
recap very quickly sure let's see I
think I said some joke about a washed-up
pencil pusher now did the robot voice
the robot voice you were doing when you
were implied I'm a rule-following robot
I want to hear it again sir robot has a
terrible robot voice yep the next time I
see you I'd like you to be wearing a
necktie Oh actually the last captain
didn't care if we wore ties well your
new captain does and more importantly he
cares that you follow his direct orders
everyone I'm the new commanding officer
captain ray Holt speech that was my
speech short sweet what do you need
Quasimodo I gotta go meet Boyle and
Peralta there's something wrong with the
captain it seems like he's in a bad mood
I don't know who could tell you're a
captain tough weekend I went to Barbados
with my husband we won't hats out of
palm fronds and swam with the stingrays
I've never been happier guys impossible
to read don't even try that is without
question the funniest story I've ever
heard
the question is who here does the best
impression of captain Raymond Holt
you'll be judged on voice body language
and overall lack of flair everyone will
perform the same scenario captain Holt
eating a marshmallow for the very first
time let the whole table begin
what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me sugar and this is quite sweet
that's your Holt impression I can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow I don't care for it
classical music what's going on here
what are you doing captain hey nothing
just eating some marshmallows care for
one
mr. Milo I know it
whoa what's with the cast I sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off
leave the guy alone all right huddle up
everybody bring it under him so he
wouldn't say what happened which can
only mean one thing he's in a Fight Club
no he did it doing something he's
embarrassed by like smiling only
question is how do you hurt your arm
smiling could be a sports injury I
sprained my wrist in college playing
field hockey
Bin's field hockey yeah it's much more
violent than the women's game we're not
allowed to wear anything that protects
our breasts attention everyone
I can hear you speculating about the
nature and origin of my injury from my
office I tripped over an uneven sidewalk
I did not think it was relevant to your
jobs the jobs which you should all be
doing right now get to work
do you want to know how I actually hurt
my wrist
yes I was looking Kevin and I attend a
class for fitness and for fun oh my god
I've mastered all the moves the pizza
toss the tornado the Scorpion the oopsie
doodle why are you telling me this
because no one will ever believe you no
son of a [ __ ] I need someone to take
this personality test for my psych class
I was hoping to WoW my professor with a
genuine psycho like Amy or Hitchcock or
Charles would be great I'm not a psycho
but I could take your test
that would be awesome I do need to warn
you that the results can be both
unflattering it's okay I'm no stranger
to unflattering test results your blood
pressure's normal normal take it again
yeah um I just wanted to thank you for
all your help yesterday I didn't do much
there was nothing good day what's going
on just very busy get back to work what
are you having they're large oh my god
captain she is magnificent then - sure
he's everything ok so do know I lost my
ring do you see where when actually it's
behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one are you trying to
Monty Hall me it's unbelievable
I don't need Monty Hall ruining my place
of work with Monty Hall has already
ruined my home life well sir the math
thing isn't the problem nightshifts
keeping you and Kevin apart you two just
need a bone
I said you two need a bone Oh dare you
detective Diaz I am your superior
officer whoa what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business don't
ever speak to me like that again I hate
that dude his pen up no he knows problem
solved
Oh captain I know you don't want to talk
about Monty Hall but I did contact a man
no need Santiago it's all good sir fight
with Kevin is over yep because you
understand the map nope
hey guys you guys yep knew it see what
happen is your dad had sex okay
9:01 Amy Santiago is officially late for
the first time ever all right let's do
this who's got theories alarm didn't go
up
all three alarms all with battery backup
come on who wants to take this seriously
Oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about
super dark Boyle the way more plausible
than the Sarge's idiotic alarm clock
theory I bet she tucked herself into bed
too tight and got stuck maybe she fell
into another dimension where she's
interesting it's 9:00 a.m. why is no one
working Amy Santiago is a few minutes
late and we're all trying to guess why I
like to play all right say she's in line
at the bank this is fun it is fun but
you're all wrong
she clearly slipped through a subway
grate and is having terrible sex with a
mole man there she is
Amy where have you been we've been
worried sick do you care to explain
yourself I'm just 70 seconds late it's
not a big deal don't worry about it
Santiago you will tell us and you will
tell us now there's a problem at the
bank cocktail good morning yes alta
captain you're smiling it's very weird
like seeing a turtle out of its shell
I'm happy our Drug Task Force was a
success and today I get to watch my
nemesis madeline wuntch drape a medal
around my neck also we clean up the
streets yeah sure that's good too
so I've been planning how to zing
Madeline when she puts the medal on I
have the perfect line once time is over
so it's a play on lunchtime yes
devastating burns sir but you know what
would really show her is if you said
nothing at all no interesting
interesting let let Madeline know she's
not even worth my staying up all night
crafting zingers lunchtime took you all
night
trust me turn the other cheek which I
recently learned is about faces and not
butts but works either way yes I should
be the bigger person
shouldn't be hard given that methods not
technically a prison for meritorious
service the NYPD bestows this award on
detective Rosa Diaz Jake Peralta and
captain Raymond Holt
Raymond Madeline you one go ahead and go
out you toad thank you for this honor
deputy chief no okay you're welcome
watch time is over no regrets
Bulger Meza me someone had a good time
in Paris Oh Kevin and I shared a perfect
week together I feel like I'm floating
on a lost song I wonder why people don't
just break in a song more often I've
been asking you for months if I could
answer the phone like give it a whirl
girl guys he's rhyming he's telling Gina
to sing captain Holt is on a vacation hi
he will say yes to anything right now I
would like a police horse and I'd like
Terry to be riding it almost constantly
I like an HR person to remind everyone
about workplace boundaries the Japanese
make toilet seats would squirt a heated
jet of water right up here I'm gonna
stop you right there bud
what we meet in here is an armored
personnel carrier I take two tanks I
want to take two great so everyone gets
a tank just remember we can't ruin
captain Holt's vacation high so no one's
saying anything it'll upset him oh no
what are those morons doing in there
maybe it's not that bad maybe they
didn't upset him what did you do what'd
you say nothing we just said welcome
back and laughed with him about all the
weight he gained in France why is
everyone just standing around get back
to work so long tank tech I gained three
pounds in Paris three pounds
you